[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Chris Wallace in for Brett Baier
President Trump says he was surprised by
domestic abuse allegations against one
of his top aides and wishes him well in
the future
staff secretary Rob Porter has cleaned
out his desk but there appears to be
increasing pressure tonight on other
Trump aids for what they knew about the
accusations and when they knew them from
the White House kevin cork tells us just
because porter is gone does not mean the
controversy is going away
good evening Kevin you're right on the
money about that Chris good evening to
you now Rob Porter's career here at the
White House may be over
but there are increasing new questions
tonight about the win White House
officials first became aware of the
allegations surrounding their former
staff secretary he did a very good job
when he was in the White House and we
hope he has a wonderful career and
hopefully he will have a great career
ahead of him the president's comments
about Rob Porter didn't quell the
controversy surrounding the White House
is handling of the former staff
Secretary's departure if anything he may
have ignited a new one as you probably
know he says he's innocent and I think
you have to remember that he said very
strongly yesterday that he's innocent so
you'll have to talk to him about that
despite Porter's repeated denials and
questions about win the White House
learned of the full scope of the
allegations against him the National
Organization for Women called on White
House chief of staff John Kelly to
resign saying the retired Marine general
was quote an enabler of domestic
violence that followed reports that
Kelly and white House Counsel done began
knew about the abuse allegations
involving Porter for months The
Washington Post said magan first learned
of the allegations in January in June
the FBI warned the White House about
them in September the news finally
reached Kelly but Porter stayed on the
job until photos of the alleged abuse
surfer's this week no question that
could have handled it better it seems
like the process they were supposed to
have in place failed the checks and
balances which should have been in place
have failed you know the public reports
now say that multiple people in the
building were made aware of this over
the course of the last few months Kelly
wrote an email to staff yesterday that
read in part I want you to know that we
all take matters of domestic violence
very seriously
domestic violence is a pourraient and
has no place in our society it's not the
first time Kelly has found himself at
the center of a White House controversy
during an interview with Fox News's Bret
Baier he suggested the president was
quote evolving on the border wall
something the president immediately
denied on Twitter he also said some
undocumented immigrants were quote too
lazy to sign up for daca and wrongly
accused a Florida congresswoman of
grandstanding at a building dedication
in 2015 but refused to apologize and I
don't think I'm being fired today
and I'm not so frustrated in this job
that I'm thinking of leaving that was
Kelly back in October and while he
didn't step down then new questions
about his handling of the abuse
allegations could cost him his job now
vice president Mike Pence was asked
about this porter controversy he is
traveling abroad representing to the
u.s. at the Olympics he was asked about
this during a stopover in japan Chris
and he refused to weigh in back to you
Kevin cork reporting from the White
House Kevin thank you